manifestations un peu partout en france
aujourd'hui un collectif du sangle
soixantaine d'associations dont la manif
pour tous appelés à manifester dans plus
de 60 villes des rassemblements contre
le projet de loi bioéthique notamment
contre l'ouverture de la pma toutes les
femmes
à paris la manifestation partira dans
une heure de la place vendôme le
rassemblement imiter à 1000 personnes en
raison de la crise sanitaire a bondi sur
une vingtaine de personnes se sont
réunies ce matin pour distribuer des
tracts et faire signer une pétition
contre cette mesure adoptée le 1er août
dernier à l'assemblée nationale je
respecte la démocratie mais sur sur les
sujets sociétaux
ça me paraît important de dire que la
société aujourd'hui je pense que elle
s'imagine qu'elle construit son bonheur
avec avec les lois qui avant cela c'est
la pma mais demain ce sera la gpa et moi
je pense qu'en fait la société elle se
trompe
elle poursuit pas son bonheur donc je
viens pour dire que je pense qu'on se
trompe
collectivement et je pense qu'on fait
fausse route il s'agit de de
l'épanouissement de l'enfance et du
refus de la fabrication de bébés
artificielle avec toutes les dérives que
cela peut comporter en matière de génie
sme en matière de trafic
de trafic de humains et de fric on prive
de fait un enfant pour contenter finale
de ces droits
donc le droit à voir comment dire accès
à sa filiation et à savoir d'où il vient
uniquement pour contenter finalement
comme je le dis souvent des désirs
d'adultes et je trouve ça extrêmement
grave parce que l'objectif c'est quand
même de veiller à l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant